[Music]
so a year and a half ago I decided I
really hated my Mac I've done many
things since then due to this fact I did
not like the touch bar on the Mac but
I'm definitely not against the Apple
ecosystem and around that same time
Apple released one of the most amazing
devices on earth which is the iPad pro
up until this point in time I don't
think it was just as easy to carry only
an iPad and actually be productive I was
doing it but it wasn't as good
now with this because we have a genuine
USB C port on here I'm going to show you
how you can actually be productive on an
iPad pro with one of these so this is a
forty-percent keyboard a cortex core it
has 47 keys it fits in a Nintendo switch
case which means you can put the iPad
and your switch into by basically a size
of a purse without having to you know
stress too much over it so once and if
you have the right dongle now you can
plug in HDMI and USB at the same time so
another key bit is being able to run
your keyboard and your screen at the
same time so let's see if this works
let's plug in so now how do you like how
do I develop okay well it's not working
now we're not getting any video anybody
had the Apple dongle on them because of
this I had the Apple dongle earlier and
you got we've walked off literally no I
know it's you do can't borrow it real
quick oh here we go
it was a race Gregor ones
let's see if this works
should work yay okay so how do you
develop on an iPad for forcing abhi is
like how do I get my code on my iPad so
you can use working copy and so you
launch working copy and I can actually
now pull out repositories see all the
commits do all the changes I can
actually get clone I can get push I can
branch I can do all the things I need to
do and do to the new Apple files I can
actually see all my files in the
filesystem I can folders so I can now
open up that same repository see all the
code I can now edit the code using text
tastic so I have an IDE built into my
local files you and a working copy I can
go into salt and actually pull and
receive code right there it does support
the full see here we go do I go you know
full syntax highlighting a lodge as if I
want to run code locally
I have Python ista available to me this
actually allows me to run real bona fide
Python so now I can do import random and
do random Dutch you know you guys get
the idea here but it gives me a nice
little IDE for doing full-blown real
Python which is nice because then I can
open up code from you know any kind of
anything that's available to the files
app inside of the iOS system which is
nice I have the same thing set up for
like github browsing so there's a code
hub tool for actually logging into
github and grabbing code directly off
the github same thing for bitbucket
if I want to debug HTTP calls like Web
API calls things like that this HTTP
flow will actually allow me to see the
full web flow so if I actually wanted to
check this out I see that I can get the
you know headers for any of the specific
items so I can actually do real
debugging of web web applications on the
go and the last thing I want to show you
well two things for want to show you
sometimes you're in an airplane at
30,000 feet and you can't get access to
the internet very easily - which if you
guys are on a Mac
is it a Mac app that gives you offline
application or offline access to your
documentation the same thing is true on
the iPad you have - the iPad full
offline documentation I don't need to be
connected and I can grab any of the docs
for the things I'm using so full docs
it's all basically based on Sphinx
listening stocks and now if I want to
run since everyone loves jupiter
notebooks in the last two lightning
talks have included jupiter notebooks I
feel like my lightening talk should also
include cheaper notebooks
there is a jupiter notebook client for
the iOS ipad called was that thing
called Juno Juno connect and when you
Mangino connect you can actually connect
to a remote running kernel in the cloud
someplace so I mentioned there's as your
notebooks Co calc binder and so if we
click on just try this will spin up a
docker image in the cloud and run the
Jupiter notebook remotely but using the
front end right here on the iPad so it's
actually launching the container right
now and then I'll be able to actually
step through I go a live jupiter
notebook running somewhere else come on
here we go
so run next so you can see that it runs
the code remotely but i guess i get all
the results here locally and that is how
you give you a road warrior on an ipad
and not to bring your laptop anymore
ever again
[Music]